the daughter of actress laurie lachlan
and fashion designer massimo gianouli
is speaking publicly for the first time
since her parents were convicted in the
college admissions scandal
21 year old olivia j gianouli broke her
silence yesterday on the facebook watch
show
red table talk her parents paid bribes
and were accused of
faking their daughter's resumes to
ensure they both got into college
carter evans reports i don't want
pity i don't deserve pity we messed up i
just want a second chance to be like i
recognize i messed up
in her first public comments olivia jgia
newly recalls the moment she found out
her parents were arrested
telling red table talk co-host jada
pinkett smith she was on a spring break
trip
when she got a call asking if she'd
spoken to her mother
i didn't know what she was talking about
but i was like i'm just going to search
my mom's name up
then it's everywhere and i remember just
like freezing and feeling
so ashamed last year actress lori
lockland and her husband massimo
gianouli were accused of paying
half a million dollars to get their two
daughters into usc
after initially fighting the charges the
couple pleaded guilty in may
and are now in federal prison gia newly
sentenced to five months and lachlan
two months i'm super close with my
parents especially my mom she's like my
best friend
i know she's strong and i know it's a
good reflection period
the 21 year old said at first she didn't
see anything wrong with what her parents
did
my parents came from a place of just i
love my kids i just want to help my kids
in their heads it was like i'm just
going to donate to a school like all my
friends did with their kids
she says she now sees things differently
that's embarrassing within itself that i
walked around my whole 20 years of life
not realizing like
you have insane privilege you're like
the poster child of white privilege
and you had no idea do you have any
understanding of why i would be upset
at your being here and what you all did
i would also love to hear it from you
because i feel like it's
a good learning thing i think i can
understand how wrong it is and
we had the means to do something and we
completely took it and ran with
it and it was something that was wrong
gia newley says she hasn't been able to
speak with her parents since they began
their prison sentences
likely because of covid protocols no
matter what the situation is you don't
want to see your parents go to prison
but also i think it's necessary for us
to move on
right and move forward for cbs this
morning carter evans
los angeles some acknowledgement there
yeah sounds like it's a big lesson
learned for everybody i think it's
really
telling that she said i didn't even know
it was wrong yeah
and i think people she admits that yes i
think a lot of people are privileged or
raised that way if that's all you know
you don't realize it's wrong so i think
it's been a great lesson for her and
everybody else
who thought the way that she and a lot
of 20-year-olds don't know a lot exactly